Hello and welcome to fire learning.
So at the beginning of this series we
talked about what started the Viking age.
And after that we talked about in the
last video we talked about the Viking age
itself. Oh, it's so far.
We've only talked about the Vikings
as Raiders warriors and conquerors.
And if we're going to
talk about the vikings,
we have to talk about them as
settlers and colonists as well.
The vikings very quickly
developed a mastery of navigation.
I had really not been seen
in Europe prior to this time,
and this led them to go on and not only
settle this and lands such as the Faroe
Islands and Iceland,
but furthermore to go where no
European nation had gone before,
to Greenland and into North America.
And in this video,
we're going to talk about that.
So firstly,
the Norris arrived in and began to settle
the 18 Faroe islands located here west
of Scandinavia, northern Scotland.
Remember, of course that didn't,
Norris had already settled the Scottish
islands around 800 a d so not long after
the Viking age officially began,
just seven years. In fact,
the word for it comes from Freud are
the old and the worst word for sheep.
They were likely not
the first inhabitants.
There's a good deal of evidence that
Celtic people's or perhaps other
Scandinavians predating his era
had attempted settlement here,
but the Viking influence in colonies on
these islands is what would last at the
modern day.
As I hinted towards a lot of evidence
indicates that a lot of these settlers
came from the north colonies and the
British isles and such in DNA research on
the moderate and how it ends throws a
mix of both Norris and Celtic ancestry.
Later though many Norwegians also came
to the islands for a number of reasons
likely to escape corrupted rural at home,
they founded a number of settlements
including tore shop in which still exists
as the capitol of the islands.
To this day,
many inhabitants here
believes that the log team,
which is a kind of Congress or problem,
it is the oldest still
running in the world.
Large team or look ting as it
seems looks a lot like law thing,
which is exactly what it means.
Kind of similar to how the word republic
comes from the Latin race public,
meaning that public thing.
This reiterates that the vikings were
somewhat democratic around the same time
as a settlement of the Faroe Islands
of Vikings ran into nearby Iceland.
I did a video on ice and already,
but I think will improve here on the
scratchy audio in poor presentation skills
of my earlier fiber learning days.
So settlement of Iceland's began around
870 [inaudible] though much like the
Faroe Islands,
other people specifically the Celts had
been here slightly earlier than a Norse.
However,
Iceland at this time was for the most
part on inhabited and the Norris with
their livestock and farming interests.
We're very interested in available land
according to the legend of Viking from
Norway names and the daughter was
the first viking to land on Iceland.
He called the island is snail land,
land to snow later on,
a viking name thrown off from the flow,
keep vulgar.
Darson set up with his
crew to voyage to Iceland.
He brought with him three
birds from the Faroe Islands,
one of which when released began to fly
toward Iceland and they follow it to
find the island.
They stayed for a considerable amount of
time though after having great trouble
finding food. And after a hard
winter killed all of flunkies cattle.
He grew angry and exhausted in called
the island Iceland out of spite.
So it's important to note that many of
these north and and just put everything
to ship one day and see, I'll tell
land that they knew nothing about it.
So the majority of the first settlements
in a lot of these places, not just ISS,
began only as temporary outposts.
According to Viking accounts,
the first long term settlers were men
under angle for our nurses and eight 74
armerson settle in a place they called
Reiki Arvik, meaning the smokey cove,
Reykjavik to this day remains
the capital city of Iceland.
I considerable number of people
followed him perhaps during the age of
settlement up to 20,000 people settled.
Iceland's the age last a
little bit less than 80 years.
Iceland while being a fascinating
place is appropriately named.
It doesn't have much fertile land,
and by the early 10th century,
the available land on the
island had been mostly occupied,
much like the Faroe Islands.
Many settlers were from the north
colonies and the British isles.
And in later Norwegians fleeing the
rule of King Harald Fair Norseman very
likely discovered Greenland
northwest of Iceland,
accidentally North's accounts state
to gum Bjorn Oates and was sailing to
Iceland, had been blown off course
heavily by a storm. When he recovered,
he noticed a number of islands off the
coast of what is now known as Greenland.
And accordingly, he is credited with
discovery of it also. Accordingly,
a number of places in Greenland to this
day are named after him in the late 10th
century of famous Vikki, known as Eric
Thor vaults, and better known as Erik.
The red after the color of his hair
was banished from Norway for committing
manslaughter.
He then moved to Iceland where he was
banished again for three years for
committing murder.
Now,
Iceland was a little bit more peaceful
than the typical north settlement,
but imagine being too violent for
the vikings. According to legend,
during his banishment,
he sailed north alone to a mysterious
island about which very little was known.
He found it and explored it,
claiming many parts as his own.
After his banishment had ended,
he returned to Iceland to
tell the locals of this place.
He called the place Greenland.
The places he discovered certainly were
habitable and indeed the climate was
warmer than it is today.
Greenland is probably the least
green of all the northern colonies.
Obviously this was false advertisement
directed towards the north of Iceland,
the particularly those who had settled
pour in disagree of land in the year 985
a great number of north set sail
for the colony on Greenland.
The Norris per usual preferred
to settle near fewer words,
which are inlets of water
located between two clips.
Such settlements included
[inaudible] founded by Eric,
which meant the steep slope.
Greenland became thus medieval Europe's
far this frontier and being a part of
North America.
One could argue that these were the first
European settlements in North America.
Regardless of that argument,
however,
the north was soon make their way
to the North American mainland.
The vikings were not the first to
settle Greenland though either.
They may very well have
been the first of Europeans,
but a number of inhabitants from
North America to called the doorstep.
People had already been living
on the island as well. However,
interaction between the people indigenous
to the area and the north settlers did
not take off until the 13th century.
However,
eventually mysteriously the Greenlanders
and the people of their homelands lost
contact with each other much later on in
history and in 1721 Danish or Norwegian
explorers found no European
descendants on the island.
We'll discuss what happens later on in
the series during the voyage degree in
Linden nine 85 one of the shifts is blown
off course and as is consistent with
Viking history being blown
off course from time to time,
tennis a lead you to a
magnificent discovery, Vr,
any hair you offs and reported finding
lands west of Greenland being very
focused on returning to Greenland.
He did not go out to
explore the land from south,
but he did tell Eric the Red
Sun Life Erickson about it.
Life is described as a tall,
strong and capable individual and
was a worthy heir to his father.
Life wanted his father
to lead an expedition.
The lands west of Greenland and
his father reluctantly agreed,
but Eric was injured in preparing for it.
He fell off his horse on his
way to the ship and told life,
I am not meant to discover any
more lands besides this fun.
This was seen as an omen,
but life persisted and he
led an expedition himself.
The vikings weren't exactly surprised at
the idea that there would be more lands
to the west. Keep in mind, even the maps,
they had a blends already known
to them were of poor quality.
They certainly weren't going to have
detailed maps of what had been poorly
explored.
If you look at their maps and examine
how they believe the world loved at the
time and they believe that the,
that west of the old world,
there was a ring of lands which,
which sort of circle back around to Africa
and that they were simply discovering
the these rings,
this ring of lands.
The discovery of North America happened
toward the ends of the Viking age.
One events symbolizing it's near end,
was the spread of Christianity.
By this time, many vikings, including
life, had converted to Christianity.
He'd life had been largely responsible.
In fact,
for spreading the religion to Greenland.
He was asked by the King of Norway to
bring a priest to a settlement with him.
However, his father, Eric, did
manage to hold onto his pagan ways,
as did a number of other vikings who
felt threatened by the new religion,
so life and his expedition set out
sailing to the lands west of Greenland.
Soon came to a land which
he called to Lou land,
which many people believe today is
Baffin Island and island north of Canada.
He found the land in
hospitable and he moved on.
He came to a place he called
and mark land of forested area,
which was very likely modern
Labrador trees, by the way,
were considerable interest to the vikings
due to the short supply of them in
places like Iceland and
especially Greenland and the
necessity of them in many
aspects of biking ways of life must
specifically shipbuilding later on,
Europeans would use North American
what to build their ships as well.
He continued to say all,
but he realized that winter was coming.
Life decided to camp and a
place south of mark land,
which he called [inaudible]
Finland according to the
sagas life claim that wild
grapes and wheat grew all
across the land and no,
it'll be vin Lind means wine land or
even grape land where they're really wild
grapes here. Well, possibly there
were grapes for the down south,
which they may have gotten a hold of,
but much like Greenland,
it might've been a little
bit of a misleading name. In
order to attract settlers.
Think of how attractive wild wheat and
grapes sounds to destitute farmers in
Greenland.
As I said,
life set up base in Vineland directing
half of the expedition to stay at base
and the other half to keep exploring.
It was somewhere during this voyage where
in the Vikings and counter people they
called it this Grayling's
and native Americans.
The names scrolling tells people all
about what the black in relationship with
the natives was like. The
word means retroed ones. Well,
first interactions may have been peaceful.
North's accounts all tell of eventual
violence and hostile relations.
This mixed with the fact that the
colony of Finland was dependent on
interactions with the feeble Greenland
colony is likely why the binland colony
eventually failed.
Life eventually returned to Greenland
where his father Eric soon died of a ds,
a disease affecting the entire colony.
Life subsequently became chieftain
of the call and he was kept busy with
Greenlandic affairs for
the rest of his life.
Though his siblings and other vikings
did attempt to reestablish in North
American call need for the
aforementioned reasons it failed.
One of life's brothers in fact
was killed and about it. Well,
the native Americans in the colony
was totally abandoned. However,
it is interesting to note the Norse,
we're still gathering wood from
Markland as late as the 14th century,
so they had been aware of this outpost
and encountering natives for hundreds of
years.
It's interesting to consider what would
have happened if the north colonies had
succeeded and if they would've maintained
peaceful relations with the natives.
Keep in mind of course,
that their discoveries per data
Columbus's by over 400 years,
if the colony of villains
had persists to the north,
may have not only maintain
a strong social, cultural,
ethnic, linguistic, et Cetera,
prejudice presence in Canada,
but they in custom with north north
lifestyle could have persisted in colonize
much more of North America. Where exactly
was Finland though for a long time.
In fact, up until only recently, it was
not really known. People had guests,
obviously it was somewhere in Canada or
perhaps even the northern United States
due to the references of grapes
and the climate and such things,
but in the 60s to know regions,
how it go.
And Anna instead using references from
locals who believed in nearby runes were
native American in origin and using Viking
details from their maps and the sagas
discovered what they believed to have
been the viking colony in Los Oma.
Doze on the tip of Newfoundland.
The architecture of the settlement is
the presence of things such as iron and
other details or reinforced the likelihood
that this is the Vin Lynde and the
Norse Sagas.
And from all of this we may gather very
obviously the vikings were not just
Raiders or murderers or Congress,
but there were also explorers and settlers
who extended far beyond the reach of
any Europeans at the time.
Now throughout these videos,
I kept referencing viking accounts and
the Norse Sagas and some of the next two
videos.
I want to read two stories from the
Viking Sagas to gain a more direct insight
into the Viking perspective.
So to keep up with these videos
and more videos like this,
be sure to check out fire learning
and subscribe. Thank you for washing.